the world wants to know what it's like
to date Terry Crews and the world needs
somebody to be their romantic icon and I
am that person thank you again so much
for meeting me on such short notice
yeah you got it uh I met Keith for the
first time today you know he's you know
pretty nice guy yeah oh that's all I
thought of one get chips I'm gonna have
a little more I just hope that he and I
hit it off and we have some things to
talk about to the most handsome date
I've ever had yeah Cheers who is the
real Terry like I'm a painter artist
I've designed furniture a lot of that
comes doing I enjoy you know going for
new things you know I have a philosophy
on life where the key to success is
doing what you want and if it's not what
you want
are you really successful you got to
understand with me is that I was in the
art world and sports world at the same
time and I saw no difference really when
I got cut from football teams I was on
16 to 7 years when I played in the NFL I
would go back in the locker room and ask
my teammates if they wanted portraits
painted of them and that's how survive
there's no reality where you would Amy
yeah let's let's move on okay um I
thought it would be nice if you know we
shared some chocolate I don't know if it
would beat you crazy if we maybe fed
each other why don't you feed me for us
too we had been going at a real nice
pace
I didn't ramped up they're like a
hundred I was kind of like whoa like you
know you're touching the chocolate
obviously when you have you know the
body Terry has it comes with a little
bit of machismo right you don't want to
show
just anybody can feed you a chocolate
just yeah what I'm a trapping so they
have about jolliness to you oh nothing
houses to you and I have a night worse I
don't just try yeah yeah I you know I
fed him like a man that smells pretty
good yes yeah we're good okay it was
something you know what is next for you
you have Brooklyn nine-nine it's doing
great it's awesome man
you're an artist you're a painter you're
an actor what else you know what I never
thought I'd be an actor ever
but I also I'm leaving space for
something else I don't know what's
coming one dream I have and this is no
joke I'm so serious
I'm on a farm I'm not even kidding
I want my own why do you wanna farm here
I'm going to have a bar what kind of
plants it kind of animals what come with
I'm gonna have everything I made a
horses
chicken response oh it's hard to make
them all and you should think of it and
then I'm gonna have hire a bunch of
people yeah but now you get that's it I
don't know what I mean though it's real
looks like I tell you if you don't have
shepherding experience it's got it
rattled that many animal no but I would
have like an app so I could walk like a
little like a watering water but I would
make it totally automated like a sniper
farm if we cyber farm
exactly exactly because I probably
couldn't be there all the time
yeah so but I would have a staff you're
in too much demand I'm so lucky to have
this time cuz I think everybody kind of
wants a PC you to you you're with me up
here man oh you know what at first they
look like wow you know you know just
what say okay oh wow
Wow I have one more little surprise for
you I know that I don't actually have a
firm place you know in your family in
your future no no no no no no you can
come yeah yeah it's all good man
maybe Thanksgiving maybe not thanks I
can brine the hell out of it no it would
be kind of one of the kind of like off
day you know like and I just straight
out had to say no I just had to bust
that bubble right away it was good the
bubble was getting bubblicious to your
future Terry thank you Thank You G mmm
that's good
all right thank you ah this is really
really awesome um
can we hug like a one-armed look gosh
I'd love a two-on-one
you know this buddy cause we can keep
our pelvis is really far apart ah let's
just do the one arm that's what I wanted
that's that's one of me that just hug I
would yeah okay
that's what I wanted look a good fight
it feels the same smell so good too okay
I went into this date with a little bit
of doubt of where I would fall in
Terry's life and I think we might have
fallen a little bit for me you are a
great person
would I ever go on another date with
chief if I want to be on BuzzFeed again
yeah yeah I'd do it so don't forget your
flower
oh no yeah let's put a family very much
thank you
I know I know okay